what's your relationship and your
school's relationship generally speaking
again with teachers units in Chicago
wait I don't know what I don't really
know what to say about him so we're
currently you don't have a cozy
relationship with the unions right now
we have no relationship and I prefer to
keep it up baby there you go please much
my attention
this week Angie's image can be taking an
unprecedented the state of American
school NBC did me a favor too sweet two
hours on national television to talk
with teachers they took my little pop
gun and made it into a howitzer you say
no one wants lousing teachers but there
are a lot of really lousy teachers who
are protected by this current system and
so like now America knows you can spend
22 grand on board black Hispanic kids
and you can give them a terrible system
I'll tell you right now Randy and I want
to know after the break why we can't use
pay to inspire teachers why not this
feels like as positive as shift in
thinking as I've been part of for a
while Democrats to their credit
increasingly still by no means the
majority have slowly but surely gotten
religion when it comes to school choice
most people know you as a democratic
consultant what's going on what brought
you to the school choice movement I just
think we ought to look the way things
just aren't working and I think
everybody has to admit that reformers
and non reformers like and say oh we can
work with the unions shouldn't we try
they're not going away anytime soon
really we can't make them go away you
know I I don't want to demonize teachers
I don't demonize the Union I don't
that's not why I'm here by conceding and
trying to be conciliatory for all these
years we gave them the upper hand we
have to do is get everybody to the table
quite frankly a little disingenuous for
the Union presidents stand up and say we
liked what Michelle was doing we wanted
to continue to happen when that when the
national a of T poured a million dollars
into the campaign in Washington DC a
million dollars into a local mayoral
race Sheba Sheree is angry at randy
weingarten concerning the election the
problem with charter schools is they
only serve some of the kids when in fact
you are advocating for caps all those
effective charter schools justifiable I
think she got a right to be angry sure
they also have the ability the freedom
of speech and all the other stuff to say
and do what they they've done the
audience in this room
just finished watching an extraordinary
powerful film called waiting for
superman which opened just a few days
ago this isn't some Hollywood drama or a
romance like this is a documentary about
our failing education system and the
tears we saw in this room are about our
children what's happening is that like
what is a policy decision is starting to
become a social decision and you see
that playing out in the vehicles that
embrace the message the film is like a
perfect 10 one of those school for these
kids their only chance at getting into a
great school depends on whether their
number is picked in a lottery so
Francisco doesn't get in is there
another chance no when the message is
like that simple and powerful like you
win 1810 how can you just be dead set
against something that I think you know
it's sort of proven that it's working 12
it's not perfect not solving every
problem but how do we take all the best
things that we've learned start
reforming real reform of what's not
working and start moving to a system
that works Sooey and the last number